not only is this a great day
for every little girl in america
this is a great day for america amy
coney barrett is a class act she has
always found her place in this world
tonight she has found her place exactly
where she needs to be
she has the temperament of exactly what
we need
she is a brilliant woman full of grace
she is the mother that i wished every
child had
today god really smiled on us and he
gave us
amazing grace
deal voting for judge amy coney bear to
become an associate justice
on the supreme court was not just
historic for me
it was my obligation to the people of
north dakota
as well as a high personal honor you
know just over two years ago
i was engaged in another historic fight
a battle
for the seat that i now hold when late
in the campaign
the democratic incumbent i was running
against chose to engage in the smear
campaign against
another outstanding american jurist
and decided to vote against the
confirmation of
brett kavanaugh well that week that very
week
my opponent raised nearly three times
more money than i spent in the entire
campaign
that week and the supreme court became
the number one issue
in the race so
to somehow suggest there's no way no way
i would or could
suggest that this vote would be delayed
because to do so to somehow wait until
after the election
when people from someplace other than
north dakota
might be tempted to elect a president
other than
other than donald trump to nominate a
jurist
other than well let's just say the
nearly perfect
amy coney barrett to be a supreme court
justice
would rightly anger the people of north
dakota and do great damage to my
conscience
this is a great night
well it's a great day for indiana and a
great day for america
i was proud to cast my vote with great
enthusiasm
for judge amy coney barrett to serve as
associate justice of the supreme court
this has been a long process for america
but a fairly short
process with respect to procedure it's
been a long process because
there's been great efforts made by
senate democrats to try and pull
amy coney barrett into the political
fray but she resisted those efforts time
and again demonstrating
that she intends to follow the law as
written
in the constitution of the united states
we won
republicans won america won because amy
comey barrett demonstrated that
she intends to follow the law she is a
faithful constitutionalist
and we couldn't be more proud in the
great state of indiana
one of our own in just a short period of
time we'll be sworn in
as an associate justice of the supreme
court of the united states
uh it's such an honor to represent
kansans in the united states senate
something i never would have dreamed of
in my life and it's such a privilege to
be here at a time in which
amy coney barrett deserved my vote
receive my vote
as she becomes an associate justice of
the united states supreme court
it's a privilege because uh rarely in
fact i would say this is the
uh the most impressive individual that
i've had the opportunity to vote
for to go through a confirmation process
with
uh and it is the privilege of uh
allowing someone to ascend to the united
states supreme court
who shares the the belief that the
constitution is written
is the law of the land not there to
legislate
only there to be a jurist and i'm also
pleased that she's from the midwest
that she has that midwest background and
i look forward to her
faithful service to the american people
but more importantly to the constitution
of the united states
i wish her well it was a privilege to
support her and congratulations to amy
conan barrett
this evening
well i have to say this was probably the
the easiest whip we've ever had
just because we had a great story to
tell
uh we had a great nominee who
uh was her own uh best representative
when it came to convincing not only the
judiciary committee
united states senate but the american
people that she is the right person to
be the next supreme court
justice of the united states and so i'm
grateful we got a number of
judiciary committee members or we did
have here we still have one here
for the great work that they did in
preparing for this
and i will tell you that like some of my
colleagues who came before me
this is kind of what we come here for
and in fact my way
to the senate was paved by the
unprecedented
schumer filibuster of appellate court
judges back in the early 2000s
that was something that at the time
became a major issue
around the country it was probably the
principal issue
in my campaign for the united states
senate and so
it's especially gratifying to be able to
be here
this evening and to have yet another
opportunity to put
a very well qualified uh
constitutionalist on the supreme court
of the united states so i
like my colleagues join in
congratulating amy coney barrett
as the new associate justice on the
supreme court
[Music]
before coming to the united states
senate i served as
the governor of north dakota for 10
years and in that time i had the
opportunity to appoint a lot of judges i
think i appointed on the order of a
dozen judges
many to the state district courts
but also to the state supreme court and
of course
the first thing i always look for was
judicial temperament
and there's no question that amy coney
barrett has
judicial temperament i don't think
anyone can argue that
but the other thing i always look for is
a judge that would enforce the
constitution and enforce the law
somebody who is a strict constructionist
who would uphold the constitution
not legislate from the bench and again
amy coney
judge barrett has demonstrated not only
an incredible
knowledge and understanding of the
constitution and the law
but she has demonstrated very clearly
that she will uphold
the constitution and the law as is her
duty
on the supreme court and that's what's
best for my state of north dakota
that's what's best for our great nation
and so i congratulate her
and wish her the absolute best
today is an important victory for the
united states constitution
today president donald trump delivered
on one of the central promises he made
to the american people
to nominate principled
constitutionalists to the u.s supreme
court
today the republican majority in the
united states senate delivered on one of
the principal promises
we made to the american people to
confirm
principled constitutionalist to the u.s
supreme court
to everyone who values and cherishes
the constitution and bill of rights
today was an important milestone
to everyone who wants to see our rights
of free speech the right to engage
without censorship without the
government silencing you
today was an important victory to
everyone who cherishes religious liberty
the first liberty protected in the first
clause of the first amendment of the
bill of rights
the the right to live according to your
faith and your conscience without
government getting in the way
today was an important victory to
everyone who values the second amendment
right to keep and bear arms the
fundamental right
to protect your home and your family and
your life
today was an important victory the
american people
want principled constitutionalists on
the united states supreme court
and today we have cause to celebrate
that judge amy coney barrett is now
justice amy coney barrett
amy coney barrett earned her elevation
to the highest court
tonight's a great night for her but it's
also a great night for our country for
my state of ohio and for so many who saw
her
in action over the past several weeks
during this confirmation process
she earned her elevation through
sacrifice to her family
her friends through hard work
and through a distinguished legal career
both as a teacher
where she won plaudits from across the
political
and judicial philosophical spectrum
through her distinguished career on the
seventh circuit where for almost three
years now
she has shown all of us here in the
senate that we did the right thing
almost three years ago in confirming her
for that post by a bipartisan majority
she earned the right to be elevated to
the highest court tonight i'm
disappointed
that she didn't once again get a
bipartisan majority
but i will say as the people of ohio and
the people of the united states of
america looked
at her and watched her in action
in the hearings they too
believed that she deserved this
elevation a majority of americans
supported
the vote we took tonight because despite
all of the attacks on her and the
process
they realized that she has earned this
right and that she will
make them proud as a justice of the
united states supreme court
i think she has a role to play and we
talked about this in our conversation
last week to help us ensure
that the faith in the supreme court
by the american people is strengthened i
think that great institution
across the north lawn of the
congress here that great institution
will be strengthened by her and that she
has a role to play really
as a role model but also as an
ambassador she'll be the youngest member
of the court
she'll be a teacher on the court
and she will be able to help us ensure
that people understand the rightful role
of the united states supreme court to
protect and adhere to the constitution
not to legislate but to allow the
legislative branch to do its work
and then interpret those laws and the
constitution faithfully
[Music]
barrett has been confirmed how seriously
do you take those threats from some
democrats who say they will
tackle force should they win uh next
week
well of course we are fighting every day
to make sure that we hold the majority
in the united
states senate to me that is the key to
this but i absolutely
believe that the democrats will if they
take
the white house the house and the senate
change the rules dramatically and change
the country dramatically
by expanding the size of the supreme
court going from 9 to 11 or 13
and that's just one of the list of
horribles that i think they would they
would put into place
the there are a number of candidates who
are running as democrats and a number of
democrats
who are here right now who have said
they were open to this
want to do it even the senator who led
the charge
by signing a letter saying we would
never get rid of the filibuster
which they of course have to do to
expand the size of the supreme court
is now open to it the nominee for vice
president
said she was absolutely considerate so
this is to me a real threat if they
weren't going to do it
former vice president joe biden nominee
joe biden would have put an end to this
early on by saying no we're not going to
do that but by continuing to refuse to
answer the question
even when put to him by george
stephanopoulos well i'll
tell you later before we before people
before election day
well you already have over 60 million
people that have voted in this country
so he has not been forthcoming and i
believe that the threat is real and i
believe is what they intend to do
if they were able to win all three
offices which is why we're fighting so
hard
to not allow that to happen
um did the prospect that this that this
vote could trigger democrats
do something that drastic at any time
give you the confidence pause as to
whether this was the right move
given the democrats
not at all a vacancy occurred
it occurred at a time when we had both
the republicans in the majority
in the senate and republican in the
white house and historically
when either party has both of those
sides the nominating side and the
confirming side
through the history of the united states
whenever that happens you generally get
with the unified government the
confirmation occurring
when you have divided government the the
nomination does not move
forward every time the president does
nominate so no this
uh did not enter in at all but the
democrats have been saying this for a
long time when you took a look at chuck
schumer
outside the supreme court yelling the
names of gorsuch and kavanagh
and saying you then personally would pay
a price
if they didn't rule the way that chuck
schumer said they had to rule
i mean to me that was a statement that
they were that the price that they were
going to pay that the country was going
to have to pay
was that they would stack the court
they'd expand the numbers of the court
if they were ever in a position where
they had all three
uh both judicial both legislative
branches as well as the executive branch
to any scenario where republicans would
regret this that
even if say next year in the courts
they've had to pay out and they added
they have some
important so they approve the filibuster
there's no republicans have
no concerns with this vote at all
at all 52 republicans just stood up when
their names were called
and voted to confirm amy coney barrett
to the supreme court
she is eminently qualified beyond any
shadow of a doubt
the majority of americans republicans
and democrats alike combined
believe she should be on the supreme
court
and i think there's no bearing on what
the democrats would do
if they have house senate and president
even if ruth bader ginsburg had not
passed when she did
i that was their intention all the way
throughout
and if democrats do take such a step
what's your message to them by the focus
when you gain power to turn around
what would that mean number one is we
have an election that election day is
coming up
eight days from now we're doing
everything we can 20 people who voted
today
are going home tonight and tomorrow
morning
to compete to return to the united
states senate and to keep us in the
majority
and as a united team we want to make
sure they can all return
thank you
is
right now there's folks back in
louisiana there are family and friends
former teachers and classmates who have
a
lumps in their throat because amy coney
barrett
has just been confirmed as an associate
justice of peace
uh justice of the supreme court excuse
me
and of course it is their family it is
the family which influenced her so well
but i'm sure those teachers and
classmates also take a little bit of
pride
because it was also those schools saint
anne's and dominicans that also
influence
the woman with incredible poise and
grace who stood under two days of
hostile and aggressive questioning
answering them all with the depth of
knowledge that was so impressive
but justice barrett's confirmation
judge now justice barrett's confirmation
is more than just a point of pride for
family back home
it's an affirmation that the timeless
values of faith and family and community
still matter and still produce somebody
who doesn't just represent those values
but also has a deeply rooted sense of
fairness
in this way i think the greatest
commendation that will be felt is
that justice barrett will be fair to all
and that is the highest compliment that
you can give at justice
people of louisiana are proud but the
people of the united states should be
very pleased
thank you
well great congratulations to amy coney
barrett on being confirmed to be the
newest member of the united states
supreme court anybody who watched the
hearings
has seen that she is extremely well
qualified
so capable by character
credibility and most importantly
commitment to the constitution she
understands that the
role of a justice is to apply the law
not legislate from the bench so it is a
historic day
for this institution as well as for the
supreme court
from the standpoint of this institution
we have now
the republican senate in the last four
years confirmed
three conservative justices to the
supreme
court three in the last four years
it wasn't until since the time
of dwight david eisenhower when he was
president
that any president confirmed more and
he was president for eight years special
thanks to
the chairman of the judiciary committee
previous and now
senator grassley and senator graham for
their leadership
and special thanks to president trump
for nominating this nominee this new
justice
but three remarkable judges to the
supreme court
what an extraordinary night everyone we
have just witnessed the confirmation
of judge amy coney barrett to become our
newest associate justice on the united
states supreme court
and i am so proud to have been a member
of the judiciary committee
witnessing judge barrett as she went
through the confirmation
hearings answering very difficult
questions coming from both the left
and the right and the the fact that we
have seen her as such a
brilliant legal scholar as an
extraordinary
jurist someone who has been commended by
folks both on the left and the right
as she moved through this process not a
single
note in front of her and i am so very
proud of her
the way she held herself during this
difficult last two weeks
her incredible demeanor her
her temperance just extraordinary
and we have witnessed now the fact that
a conservative woman can move ahead
not be marginalized by the people on the
left
and the fact that we can now push back
and say
you know women can choose to marry who
they want to marry they can choose
whatever career path they want to engage
in
they can be the mother of seven
beautiful children
they can be a woman of faith they do not
have to march
in lockstep with what the democrats
think of
as an ideal woman and i am so very proud
of now justice amy coney barrett
and folks this is exactly what i would
want to encourage our young women to do
across the united states of america
because folks this is exactly what a mom
can do thank you
well it was exciting today it's the
first time i've gotten to vote for a
supreme court uh justice as a u.s
senator
one of the things i ran on when i ran
two years ago was the opportunity to
vote for judges that believed in the
constitution
believed in interpreting the law rather
than making the law
as governor of florida i got to appoint
407 judges and i really only asked him
one question
do you understand you're not part of the
executive of the legislative branch
and amy koenig bear clearly understands
that that's what she said when i sat
down with her
so this historic day for me i'm proud to
be here i'm proud to have been able to
vote for somebody as wonderful
as uh amy coney barrett and i know she
for the next
decade she's going to be a wonderful
member of the supreme court and do a a
great job
as you can see our numbers are growing
for
this press conference because people
want to have a good word to say
about justice barrett and about the
process
that we have carried forward it's been
such an honor to be a part of the
judiciary committee
and to work through this process with
chairman graham
who has been so capable as we have gone
through the review process and holding
the hearing we appreciate that
leadership
that was brought to this entire process
i also want to say to tennesseans how
much i appreciate hearing from them
and how they have weighed in on this
issue how i have heard from tennesseans
who said
you know i've changed my mind about who
i'm going to vote for
in the presidential race because of the
quality
of judges that we now have hit 220
judges
and because of the caliber of your
supreme court
justice nominee joni
mentioned just a touch about
how this shows that there is a place a
seat at the table
for women that come from the political
center
and center right and while our
democratic colleagues
chose to be disrespectful
of the process of the committee of the
institution
and also of judge barrett
we know that part of their frustration
was born out of the fact
that justice barrett would not submit
she would not submit
to the women's agenda that the leftists
think that a woman has to submit to
in order to be recognized as
accomplished
as fully female and she did stand
strong and tall through this process
and indeed has broken a barrier and will
open the door for other women to realize
there is a seat at the table for them
not only is this a great day for every
little girl
in america this is a great day for
america
amy coney barrett is a class act
she has always found her place in this
world tonight she has found her place
exactly where she needs to be she has
the temperament
of exactly what we need she is a
brilliant woman
full of grace she is the mother that i
wished
every child had today god
really smiled on us and he gave us
amazing grace
you know voting for jamie coney bear to
become an associate justice
on the supreme court was not just
historic for me
it was my obligation to the people of
north dakota
as well as a high personal honor you
know just over two years ago
i was engaged in another historic fight
a battle
for the seat that i now hold when late
in the campaign
the democratic incumbent i was running
against chose to engage in the smear
campaign against
another outstanding american jurist
and decided to vote against the
confirmation of
brett kavanaugh well that week that very
week
my opponent raised nearly three times
more money than i spent in the entire
campaign
that week and the supreme court became
the number one issue
in the race so
to somehow suggest there's no way no way
i would or could
suggest that this vote would be delayed
because to do so to somehow wait until
after the election
when people from someplace other than
north dakota
might be tempted to elect a president
other than
other than donald trump to nominate a
jurist
other than well let's just say the
nearly perfect
amy coney barrett to be a supreme court
justice
would rightly anger the people of north
dakota and do great damage to my
conscience
this is a great night
well it's a great day for indiana and a
great day for america
i was proud to cast my vote uh with
great enthusiasm
for judge amy coney barrett to serve as
associate justice of the supreme court
um this has been a long process
for america but a fairly short process
with respect to procedure it's been a
long process because
there's been great efforts made by
senate democrats to try and pull
amy coney barrett into the political
fray but she resisted those efforts time
and again
demonstrating that she intends to follow
the law
as written in the constitution of the
united states
we won republicans won
america won because amy comey barrett
demonstrated that
uh she intends uh to follow the law she
is a faithful constitutionalist
and uh we couldn't be more proud in the
great state of indiana
uh one of our own uh in just a short
period of time will be sworn in
as an associate justice of the supreme
court of the united states
uh it's such an honor to represent
kansans in the united states senate
something i never would have dreamed of
in my life and it's such a privilege to
be here at a time in which
amy coney barrett deserved my vote
receive my vote
as she becomes an associate justice of
the united states supreme court
it's a privilege because uh rarely in
fact i would say this is the uh
the most impressive individual that i've
had the opportunity to vote
for to go through a confirmation process
with
uh and it is the privilege of uh
allowing someone to ascend to the united
states supreme court
who shares the belief that the
constitution is written
is the law of the land not there to
legislate
only there to be a jurist and i'm also
pleased that she's from the midwest
that she has that midwest background uh
and i look forward to her
faithful service to the american people
but more importantly to the constitution
of the united states
i wish her well it was a privilege to
support her and congratulations to amy
conan barrett
this evening
well i have to say this was probably the
easiest whip we've ever had
it's just because we had a great story
to tell
we had a great nominee who
was her own best representative when it
came to convincing not only the
judiciary committee
united states senate but the american
people that she is the right person to
be the next supreme court justice
of the united states and so i'm grateful
we got a number of judiciary committee
members or we did have here we still
have one here for the great work that
they did
in preparing for this and i will tell
you that like some of my colleagues who
came before me
this is kind of what we come here for
and in fact
my way to the senate was paved by the
unprecedented
schumer filibuster of appellate court
judges back in the early 2000s
that was something that at the time
became a major issue
around the country it was probably the
principal issue
in my campaign for the united states
senate and so
it's especially gratifying to be able to
be here this evening
and to have yet another opportunity to
put a very well qualified
uh constitutionalist on the supreme
court of the united states so i
like my colleagues join in
congratulating amy coney barrett
as the new associate justice on the
supreme court
before coming to the united states
senate i served as
the governor of north dakota for 10
years and in that time i had the
opportunity to appoint a lot of judges i
think i appointed on the order of a
dozen judges
many to the state district courts
but also to the state supreme court and
of course
the first thing i always look for was
judicial temperament
and there's no question that amy coney
barrett has
judicial temperament i don't think
anyone can argue that
but the other thing i always look for is
a judge that would enforce the
constitution and enforce the law
somebody who was a strict
constructionist who would uphold the
constitution
not legislate from the bench and again
amy coney judge barrett has demonstrated
not only an incredible
knowledge and understanding of the
constitution and the law
but she has demonstrated very clearly
that she will uphold
the constitution and the law as is her
duty
on the supreme court and that's what's
best for my state of north dakota
that's what's best for our great nation
and so i congratulate her
and wish her the absolute best
you